Hey, Charles.
>> Oh, hi Michael.
>> It's funny running into to you here.
>> It is. It's always funny running in to you over the interwebs.
>> So, today, I have the pleasure
of telling you about computation learning theory.
>> Hmm, it's my favorite kind of theory.
>> [LAUGH] Well, sure. Now how do you like theory in general?
>> I am happy that there are peolpe that do theory.
>> There we go. Alright. And now you are about to be
one of those people, at least for the next you know, hour.
>> No, no. I am not doing theory.
You're doing theory. I'm listening to you do theory.
>> No. I am coaching
you through it. Don't you understand? It's about,
it's about the learning process. Learning about learning.
>> Fine.
>> So let's start out with a quiz.
No wait. So let me let me at least set
the stage as to why, what you know, what
it is that we're talking about today and how it's
different from what we've talked about, in the previous
days. So mostly what we've been talking about up to
this point, is, algorithms for doing learning. Alright we talked
about what, what learning, the machine learning field was like.
And we talked about a number of
specific algorithms for building classifiers, and building regression.
And there's a problem with that. Specifically,
I have this, this feeling that it's very,
very necessary to always make sure you
know what problem you're solving, before you start
proposing algorithms for solving it. And we haven't
really nailed down what exactly that problem is.
>> Hm.
>> And that makes things hard. It makes it hard to
know, for example, whether or not one algorithm's better than another.
>> One algorithm's better than another, if it works better.
>> If it works better? Yeah, well, you know, that's not wrong. But
I think it still is not a
very helpful definition for designing better algorithms.
>> Okay.
>> So so we're going to talk
about this computational learning theory. And I want
to say that it's not about particular
algorithms, it's about some other stuff. But I
thought it would be helpful if we started out by saying. well, what is it
that we talked about so far? So one of the things we talked about so far
is algorithms for doing for learning classifiers. So, I
wanted to draw a picture of that, and then I
realized maybe that would be actually a useful quiz.
So, if you can image each of three boxes is
the output of a classifier in a two dimensional
space. So it's a two dimensional input space. We've ran
a leaner, and when it spits out a classifier,
this is how it classifies the the regions of the
space. So I, I use blue lines to separate the
square into regions. The two dimensional space into regions, and
then I labeled each region with a minus or a
plus, so you can tell what the classifier was doing.
>> Okay. So I'm wondering if you could fill in underneath each one,
what learning algorithm was probably used to, to find this classifier?
>> maybe.
>> You want to give it a shot? It's not, it's not
that important to this lecture, but I thought it
might be helpful in just kind of setting the stage.
>> Okay. I'll give it a try.